depuis quatre ans elle écrase tout ou
presque sur leur passage
lors de leur première saison les
féminines d'elancourt terminent
troisièmes de leur championnat à 7
la seconde est stratosphérique 130 buts
marqués pour un seul encaissé
une réussite menée sous l'impulsion de
leur entraîneur dany l'aigle devenu le
sorcier il football féminin de l'eau etc
non c'est pas magique c'est que je pense
qu'on a réussi à qu'on a réussi à créer
un lien entre les joueuses moi même et
les personnes le staff
et puis les éducateurs qui est qui qui
sont là toutes les semaines pour pour
les filles et on a réussi à créer
on va dire un groupe nous famille quoi
voilà je pense qu'on tire tous dans le
même sens quand il ya des choses à dire
les choses en effet de dépasser par a
plus b la saison dernière les amazones
évolué pour la première fois dans un
championnat à onze et rate la montée
pour deux petits points avec cette
réussite l'effectif atteint aujourd'hui
40 joueuses mais les élans courtoise
doivent encore grandir comme en témoigne
leur défaite en coupe de france 9 buts à
0 face à saint maur club de division
d'honneur
évoluant quatre divisions au dessus de
l'eau et c'est ce qui va nous poser
souci ça va être d'être confronté à un
niveau et à meilleur que nous parce que
actuellement toutes les équipes qu'on a
montré qu'ils étaient meilleurs que nous
bah on était complètement déstructuré on
n'arrivait pas à jouer donc
on sait gagner mais pour l'instant c'est
pas on sait pas perdre elle encore
réussi là où de nombreux club yvelinois
se sont cassé les dents
avoir un projet viable sur la durée lors
de cette 11e journée les filles de dany
l'aigle continuent leur sans faute cette
saison en s'imposant face à colon 3 buts
à 0
avec dix points d'avancé sur leurs
dauphines et amazon ont désormais la
montée en promotion d'honneur au bout de
leurs crampons